spina bifida is one type of neural tube
defect that often occurs due to a lack
of vitamin B9 or folic acid in spina
bifida oculita which is the most mildest
form one or two vertebrae are missing in
the back of the uh at the lumbar end
in case of
meningocele the spinal cord the spinal
fluid actually pokes through the spine
forming a bulge at the back of the baby
and in the meningo myelosil
not only the fluid bulge up but the
nerve also protrude out this is the most
severe form
generally our neuralitative folds at
around day 21 to 24
and the cranial and cotton europore
closes gradually at around Day 26 when
the caudal neuropore failed to close it
leads to spina bifida and one of the
biggest risk factor of spina bifida is a
lack of folic acid